filming a world of magic can be
seriously tough in our world from almost
drowning to facing their worst fears to
some very nasty injuries the harry
potter actors endured a whole lot of
struggle so let's check out which scenes
were some of the most difficult to film
over the years was
the most horrifying thing either of us
but before we dive in you should
probably subscribe to our new channel
the things animated to get all the
hidden secrets and unique theories
behind your favorite animated movies and
shows number one
well torture is never really supposed to
be fun so i couldn't stop crying even
when you're acting opposite someone as
incredible as hell in a bottom carter
being tortured in a scene is a real
challenge watson shared that it was
quite horrible to do the actress reacted
so intensely that she actually made the
bellatrix actress and director david
yates feel uncomfortable
number two
word of advice pass on any challenges
that involve being underwater everyone
knew filming this part of the triwizard
tournament would be a challenge
dan radcliffe did some solid training
time in the pool with professional
divers to prepare for filming but he was
definitely no expert meaning at times he
forgot what hand signals meant what
communication underwater has to be done
physically so when the dive team saw the
actor giving the help me signal they
freaked out worrying that dan was
drowning this this confused me luckily
the actor wasn't in danger meaning to
signal to everyone that he was actually
a-okay
however by the end of it all radcliffe
had spent 41 hours under very cold water
he was lucky the worst he wound up with
was just two ear infections main thing
that really sort of was a bit
frustrating
number three
the room of requirement couldn't be
everything for everyone all the time
unfortunately for bonnie wright this
room full of magic and power was really
tough to work in because of how
claustrophobic she was left feeling with
dumbledore's army being so big there was
always a crowd and being confined into
such a small space left right really
struggling her on-screen brothers
weren't such big fans of the room either
the phelps twins struggled with how much
heat the fireplace is throughout the
room emitted making for some seriously
sweaty actors and all those warm
sweaters
i've never i've never told anyone on
this but i hated that requirement set
number four
her character definitely wouldn't have
felt this way imelda staunton really is
a great actress we'd never have believed
that she actually felt awful when
torturing radcliffe the always evil
character was the furthest thing away
from who staunton was and the actress
admitted that filming those scenes was a
real struggle for her calling it
horrible and unpleasant of course
daunting was left feeling guilty for
days after the fact whenever she had to
go full evil you know the scene where
she gives him the detention was
uncomfortable for me
number five
this was a doozy
cedric losing his life is very sad but
it looks fairly simple technically the
truth is though pattinson suffered
during filming because of the stunt he
had to do for it the actor was set up
with some wires wrapped around his groin
area that would allow him to roll once
hit with the unforgivable curse let's
just say our pats was very happy when
the final cut was called
number six even his co-stars were
shocked he took on a stunt this big
radcliffe had proven he could take on
some stunts himself and perform to the
caliber needed safely so by the time the
goblet of fire came around he wanted to
amp it up signing on to perform the big
slide down the roof of hogwarts for the
cameras sure he wasn't really on the
roof of a castle but the set that was
created did leave him with a 40-foot
jump on wires and it still looks pretty
terrifying i will never be allowed to do
something like that again number seven
when there are seven harry's things get
tricky we'd think that the fact that
radcliffe was the only one actually
acting out the scene when he played the
rest of his crew disguised as himself
would make things easier but it was
straight up tough and kind of endless it
took a whopping 95 takes to capture all
the action properly since radcliffe had
to act out the scene over and over again
playing each different part it was time
consuming but oh so worth it in the end
number eight
emma wasn't shy about how much she
detested this experience
yes i can tell you the worst right now
it was on movie number two we get
dropped by a dragon into the lake and
rupert wasn't so crazy about it either
considering he thought his heart stopped
beating from the cold it was the middle
of winter and the water they were in
wasn't heated and they couldn't wear any
extra layers since they had to change
out of their wet clothes so quickly
after
out of the trio watson was the only one
to have the help of thermal pants
number nine
ugh this part always makes us cry
sirius's untimely end remains one of the
top worst losses in the whole franchise
in part because of radcliffe's
heart-wrenching performance this was the
scream so blood-curdling and guttural
that the team couldn't even include it
in the film it had helen obanum carter
and emma watson in bits so we can only
imagine how brutal it was for dan in the
moment especially since he'd lost such a
close family member around the same time
number 10
it sounds like a party but emma watson
wasn't a fan let's face it kissing
someone who's like a brother is tough
doing it twice well that's just not fair
to make it all worse when emma and dan
radcliffe got together to smooch the two
of them really got stripped down and
neither one was expecting it watson
shared that it was the weirdest thing
ever and they only told us about the
silver body paint the day before watson
has been nothing but honest about the
experience explaining that it was
awkward enough as it was without the
silver paint and the strapless bra but
whatever it looks good for the story as
for kissing rupert the actress was fully
clothed but it was still tremendously
tough to get through especially because
the two had such a hard time stinging
character emma expressed her frustration
saying it was supposed to be that
dramatic kiss but rupert and i continued
to laugh i was really worried that we'd
never get to get that scene because we
just couldn't take it seriously number
11.
animals are cute until you work with
them
if any of the actors were fans of
monkeys or bats before they definitely
weren't after filming with them the
monkeys couldn't keep calm and were
harder to wrangle than the young kids
and some got a bit explicit on set and
grind had a terrible time when filming
with the bats since one of them decided
to do its business on him
yeah that ain't cute
number 12
the spider is huge rupert grint was ron
weasley in almost every way including
the fact that they both suffered pretty
serious arachnophobia the chamber of
secrets was unquestionably the actor's
nightmare aragog was portrayed by a
giant creepy animatronic puppet that
looked real enough to leave grinch
shaking in his boots he even called them
the scariest scenes to film even when
they weren't filming the presence of
aragog on set just gave rupert the
creeps
number 13.
it definitely worked in this case
professor snape love him or hate him
alan rickman gave a stellar performance
and that was partially thanks to method
acting the actor kept in character
whenever he was filming on set so the
first scene he filmed with the kids
wound up being a real challenge for them
while rickman definitely didn't mean to
he intimidated some of the young actors
so much that they really struggled to
focus
we'd be nervous too luckily that quickly
went away once they spent some time
together off camera and they saw that
smile we all love
number 14
fans of the books remember him
the character didn't make it into the
movie but rick mayall had actually been
on set and gave a very memorable
performance
so why have we never seen it well the
actor did such a wonderful job that he
caused the young actors to giggle
endlessly and remember this was for the
very first movie so these kids giggling
too long could lead to serious delays in
production they tried filming with the
actors back to the kids and with him
across the room but he was just too
hilarious every time director
christopher columbus wound up not liking
the look in the end so he just cut the
character harsh
number 15
it's fun but complicated the high flying
sport never existed before it was
written into harry potter so jk went on
to create a full detailed rulebook so
the production team could make sense of
what it was how to play and then film it
in a way that would captivate audiences
after all no one wants to be watching
these kids flying around on broomsticks
if we have no idea why harry was so
obsessed with finding that golden flying
ball aka the snitch their production
designer stuart craig was the one who
took on the daunting task of creating
what the pitch would look like and his
design worked like a charm in the later
films quidditch became some of the most
brutal scenes to film since those
broomsticks were not comfortable at all
even with the modifications made to try
and give the actors an actual seat to
sit on oh and we can't forget rupert
grint also got a quaffle to the face at
one point that's gotta hurt
number sixteen they loved it so much
they filmed it twice
okay well that wasn't the reason the
production team was forced to reshoot
the entire epilogue scene because the
first time around everything was way too
rushed and chaotic especially for such
an important moment all the actors felt
really bittersweet seeing each other
looking aged and knowing this would be
the final scene of the franchise
well we get teary eyed just thinking
about it
number 17.
who left the food out for a team that
was usually thinking about everything
it's pretty surprising that no one would
have realized what would happen to the
real food they filmed with for days on
days under super hot lights the foul
smelling set made filming a total drag
for everyone who was close enough to
smell the stench and by the time they
got rid of it that smell was seeping out
of the great hall the actors may have
been chowing down on real food for the
first day but no one was taking any more
bites once their plates were filled with
rotten food a nasty sight for them a
tasty one for us
number 18
dan says it best
we work very much just like kids being
kids on a set filming the early movies
especially the very first one was an
absolute dream for the child actors but
for the adults involved well it could be
a bit of a nightmare since filming
anything with a big group was extremely
difficult with children who were
distracted by the magic of it all and
each other the big problem was like
throughout a take
our attention would like
would wane and come and go but it was
pretty sweet to see how much the little
ones enjoyed it or they were just so
happy to be in a harry potter film that
they couldn't contain their excitement
they laughed they cried they got some
serious injuries and had some very
emotional days but they made some pretty
special memories and of course very
special movies in the process
would you have wanted to experience
filming any of these scenes